there it is there's your wolf whistle
that's the origin of that
that's a big decision to spend the hours
it will take to draw that
a look at daffy duck i mean it tells you
he's an arrogant little sh
so you're saying this is a mistake this
isn't a director's
intent no no this is a mistake
thanks to heal for sponsoring this video
stick around so you can learn more about
huel's complete protein package
hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of animators react we are here
with
eric koenig who is the very first
animator that we ever had on the show in
fact he was instrumental in even putting
this show together
what have you been up to since we saw
you last since then i took a break from
the simpsons and have
now started directing on a show called
house broken the show creators
jen crittenden gabby allen and clea
duvall
they're just wonderful to work for and
i've just had the time of my life
working on the show
well you brought a lot of clips today
oftentimes we all kind of bring clips to
the table eric
just did all of our work for us he has a
ton of cool clips
so what would you like to start with
well i thought it would be kind of fun
to
talk about directing and animation it's
kind of misunderstood people don't
really get a sense of exactly what we do
so that would be kind of fun to break
that down and show
how much the person behind the cartoon
actually affects the cartoon
and how what you're seeing really is a
reflection of the artist that's behind
it
where i thought it'd be fun to start is
actually the classic warner brothers
cartoons
there were six or seven directors
rotating on the cartoons
at the time i picked four of those
directors
they all directed daffy duck cartoons so
i thought it would be a lot of fun to
kind of compare
each of their different styles of daffy
duck i mean i know how you direct a
cartoon
you're like listen come here daddy i
wasn't i wasn't believing that line
reading there i think you got to put a
little bit more emotion into it yeah and
they're always like goofing off and
you know explosions explore
yeah you never know when you know you're
going to get a an anvil dropped on your
head it's
a real drag our first director whose
name was frank tashlin
was a real lover of the surreal
did daffy look so sad yeah and tired
when you're talking about directing an
animation you're talking about exactly
the same things
daffy duck needs to walk in and look sad
and angry so here is his whole body
is expressing that pose
[Music]
insulting my integrity you wanted to do
things
like this that you can't do in live
action i mean not with that attitude
right exactly
you know i in fact i wouldn't even want
to do that in a cg marvel movie or
whatever because it'd be
disgusting his mouth melds together like
neo from the matrix
oh yeah yeah it's it's just brilliant so
frank cashlin's
version of daffy duck is this very kind
of wacky over-the-top character and he
really pushed his
crew to just think outside of what you
can do
in live action
[Music]
and they actually like managed to draw a
reflection in the
mirror of his spectacle yeah here you
have this over-the-top cartoon but he
takes the time to
carefully take off his gloves yeah and
do that real subtle animation
the thing that always gets me is like
him taking off his glove like that's a
big decision to spend the hours it will
take to draw that you know whereas it
just feels like a passing moment here
but like no
it's very important we will spend hours
to see him take off each finger
he could have just been like and now you
have a glove so
from a directing standpoint like what
would be the main decision to take the
time to do that
it's always character and here you've
got this boss character and you're
basically wanting to kind of show that
he's
a pompous jerk a normal person would
just take their gloves off but a pompous
jerk does this
delicate little thing you know and then
of course he's running against
a madman you know in daffy duck you'll
see the very early versions of daffy
duck were just this very over-the-top
kind of
mad character you also see how he's
drawn with kind of the circular face and
the really long beak
but you can use the whole body to
express your acting
i did notice a weird glitch where daffy
duck flips
the other direction for one frame right
here oh yeah
wait is it the actual it's the back of
this it's the back of the cell that is
really important
back in the day the animators would draw
with pencil and paper
from there a group would then trace the
images on celiophane which is like clear
plastic
and then flip it over to the back and
paint the back of the image
and those were called cells in this case
the camera guy was probably up at two
o'clock in the morning filming this
scene
and he made a mistake and he grabbed his
stack of from the sack of cells and put
it upside down
and either they ran out of time or
didn't notice it
so you're saying this is a mistake this
isn't a director's
intent no no this is a mistake this is a
80 year old mistake that you get
and whoever that is is probably really
pissed at you right now because you
pointed it out
i'm going to get haunted his grandkids
are really pissed at you
[Music]
us army announces a smashing frontal
attack
so the next director bob clampett his
cartoons are a little bit more
grounded in a reality than frank
cashland's
oh hooray fall for red white and blue oh
hooray for the red white and blue
so you can see here he's a little bit
more grounded in reality
a little bit yeah a little bit he's a
little bit more solid
when you're drawing animation it has to
maintain the same volumes and weight
now he doesn't like arbitrarily bloat
and stretch and like when he does
stretch he gets thinner
right so it's like it's still the same
amount of daffy duck just stretched out
or squashed together as opposed to him
just arbitrarily becoming a large or
small
character exactly the term for that in
animation is called squash and stretch
and that's the exact principle is that
when he squeezes himself his shoulders
puff up so basically the volume
of his chest now is around his neck and
it makes it feel like it's a solid thing
[Music]
the other thing that's going on is this
is called straight ahead animation which
means that the animation is moving
around so much that you can't plan
something like this out and the
animation is kind of getting discovered
as you go along
robert clampett will have drawn this
drawing
and gone to the animator and gone you
know here's a sketch of what i want it
to look like
and tell him i want him to be shaking
and then
at a certain point he's gonna jump up
and grab his throat
it's a decision of how he's gonna do it
and then that cool
stretch up which is only on a frame well
that's all a director's decision working
with the animator so it's effectively
directing a movie on a frame by frame
basis
[Music]
i'm noticing the motion lines that you'd
have to you know
imply really fast motion or motion blur
or whatever but it looks like here it's
straight up brush strokes yeah
as opposed to just like actual lines
since animation doesn't have
motion blur there's two ways to kind of
create that that sense so you can either
use dry brush
there or there's another technique and
actually that's a good segue into our
next director text avery
who is the master of what's called a
smear
is this the one with the wolf whistle
and this is the one this is where the
wolf came from
wolf whistle
the wolf was the wolf whistle
[Music]
there it is there's your wolf whistle
that's the origin of that
right yeah and there's your smears
there's your look at these out there
yeah
crazy drawings that are in there they
make no sense but boy do they work when
you play them at speed
so it's a little less about mimicking
motion blur and a little bit more about
stylizing a sense of motion
exactly that's the thing about smearing
though is that because our eyes have
this thing called persistence of vision
you know the little door stoppers behind
the door yeah flicking goes
you can clearly see the thing in two
different spots that's just interesting
because the motion blur lines are a way
to try to replicate something optically
whereas that smear thing as a way to
replicate how our eyes actually work
absolutely and adding a sense of humor
you know everything in this is supposed
to
be humorous you know in the case of this
wolf animation i mean what you have to
imagine is
on the script page it's a wolf whistles
he's excited by a girl
well that's kind of boring you know
that's right i mean that could be
anything
but in a master of text avery he had to
sit there and come up with all of these
over-the-top poses and i'm sure they
just had a blast
text avery was loud boisterous
full of life and he kind of brought that
energy into his cartoons
he draws some of the most wacky
over-the-top
you know daffy ducks i'm a hummingbird
and then look at daffy duck look at how
whacked out and stretched out
yeah it turned into a hunting
hummingbird yeah compared to the bob
clampett cartoons where he was a lot
more solid
here you're having somebody that's
saying it doesn't have to look always
exactly like daffy duck we can play with
that idea
the technical term for it in animation
is called on model when you start a
project you get a model sheet
of the character which usually just kind
of a standard standing pose and he's
drawn from
a bunch of various directions and it's
important to stay
on model but frank tashlin and tex avery
kind of let their imagination go they
they went well for this scene
he really should be stretched out and
kind of morphing his body
to better tell that moment of the story
i know what you're thinking what will i
ever do if i miss today's episode
how will i react well you know what i
know how to fix that
all you got to do is hit that little
subscribe button it costs you nothing
and it helps us
wonders thank you our final director
is a man named chuck jones and he's
probably the most famous of the warner
brothers directors i would eagle
you know argue he was a genius high
praise
yeah very high praise i may sound biased
because
i was lucky enough my very first job in
animation was actually getting to work
with chuck jones that's quite the first
job to have
whoa yeah he found a bridge between
the extremes of text avery and the kind
of morse liberty
of bob clampett and he brought a kind of
a sophistication
into his cartoons
[Music]
this one meets marvin the martian yeah i
have sent for you dodgers
because we are facing a crisis the world
supply of alludium fosdex look at daffy
duck i mean it tells you he's an
arrogant little sh
yeah like you got a lot of confidence in
a silly cape
it's hilarious hat has a cape yeah
exactly it's amazing
dodgers in the 24th and a half
century that's another real famous uh
kind of chuck jones trope he jumps up in
the air
and we're not worried about gravity and
then all of a sudden nope yeah we are
and he falls and of course you know
wiley coyote was famous for that as well
[Music]
look at that little walk across the
screen i mean like as a director you're
going well daffy duck has to kind of
sneak across
the screen so it can be you know like a
classic d
d d but chuck jones comes up with this
ridiculous pose
you know like a cartoon villain like
i liked how when he was crawling across
the ground his hat actually kind of
acted like his eyelids yeah giving him
that sly look
absolutely you really take a lot of
stuff for granted oh yeah and look at
how
chuck jones is using that cape and even
that hat
as something solid in it to ground
all the wackiness around it so the cape
is always like kind of working like a
real cape would even though daffy duck
is kind of all over the place
oops had the silly thing in reverse
some of the directors would give a
little more freedom to their animators
but with chuck jones it was like you
don't mess with chuck jones and his
drawings because there's really nobody
else that could draw better than him
that reminds me of directors who have
like a pet peeve against improvising on
set you know it's like no
do it the way it's written in the script
i know james gunn is famous for that for
like the guardians of the galaxy movies
well there's kind of two
thoughts to that if you are brilliant
like chuck jones or
james gunn it works because you're
getting a hundred percent of the auteur
but there's other directors who really
thrive on the collaboration
and it's not only 100 of you the
director it's 100 of your entire crew so
you get you know 450
that kind of segues into what i'm
working on now which is a show that's
currently airing on fox called house
broken
they are supremely confident in their
own abilities to have allowed
me to be part of the creative process
and to
come up with ideas and try and improve
things
and that's why i live in dread of
boomsday why they call it boom's day
the booms come at night nobody knows
since it's the first season we're
getting a chance to kind of create the
style
and develop our language you know what
works what doesn't work it's like your
chance to experiment and kind of throw a
bunch of things up the wall and see
what sticks yeah when we first get a
script what i like to do is take some
time
and do scribbles all you're focusing on
is the staging
and not the actual drawing of the
characters you're telling me
those red stick figures you can call it
that
are the work of a professional yeah
exactly
i get paid big bucks to do that very
thing
i call it my throw up pass i'm working
out the staging of the scene
and i'm not worrying about the drawing
because what i'm worrying about
is the mechanics of the camera the
storytelling
a little bit of the attitude of the
characters and what it gives me a chance
to do
is then start to work with the
storyboard artist and he's taken my
scribbles
and he's tied him down and started to
put the character and the acting in
you can see where it's it's derived
directly from the scribbles
by that collaboration then he can not
worry about so much of the staging and
just kind of worry about his brilliant
drawings and adding his character and
then
here's the final i can already taste
their freezer to table fish sticks
it's so nuts just to see like the before
and after here on this final pass here
they're not just taking the storyboards
he made and coloring in the lines these
are fresh new drawings that are still
inspired
by the thing that was inspired by your
scribbles right so
in a typical television show the
storyboards are done here in the united
states
and then it gets farmed out to animation
studios
our show got farmed out to studios all
over the world and then the animation
comes back and then there's a whole
another process which is called retakes
the writers who might want to change
gags and us who are seeing mistakes in
the animation
and things that we want to improve so
it's like going through and trying to
figure out
all right what needs a v2 either from a
technical standpoint or a story
standpoint exactly
there were large sections of it that
they were completely rewritten and we
had to re-storyboard and
animate for fresh you want to come eat
some day old yep
my buddy will take care of this mess
thanks pal so would you say generally
speaking once it's like
ready to air you're not necessarily
looking at glaring mistakes you're just
looking at small touches little
improvements little bits of polish here
and there that you have to kind of
decide
where your cutoff point is when you ship
it the criteria really that we
we use on the show is is it funny
does it tell the story they have a team
of in-house animators
as a director something that i really
strive to do is not to create kind of an
intimidating
bullying persona because what i found is
animation is always an energy game i
think all filmmaking is always an energy
game you're working on something
and it's as good as you can have the
energy to get it
right yes there will be times like you
talk about i will get exhausted
and i rely on the energy of somebody
else coming in with some fresh energy
and the thing i don't want to do is
stomp on their energy i've definitely in
my career worked with
directors that are bullies and they stop
you and
only want the way they want their thing
to be done and i
always felt like well yes then you will
get exactly what you
want but i feel pretty confident that i
have some chops too and
bring something to this so like i said
this experience has been a real
wonderful experience in my career
getting to do exactly that so if you
want to check out some of what we're
talking about here
in action check out house broken eric
has directed two of the episodes august
16th there's the murder mystery episode
coming out
but it's mondays at nine on your local
fox tv station
what's up guys i'm jordan and i do
production here at corridor and in my
free time i'm usually doing a lot of
fitness related activities
i love working out and that's why i'm
super excited to talk to you about our
sponsor today
hule i personally love fuel because i
don't have time
to make a huge breakfast in the morning
that gives me all of my
vitamins and minerals and protein that i
need after i work out what i do is take
a scoop of fuel
throw it in here shake it and come to
work so what is fuel what makes it
different from other proteins
heal complete protein is a 100
nutritionally complete
high protein snack made from sustainable
hemp baba and pea protein
it gives you 20 grams of protein per
serving and i have to mention
it contains all 27 essential vitamins
and minerals
it's super low in sugar and it only has
105 calories per serving
so there were six different flavors to
choose from i chose the chocolate fridge
brownie
and it was delicious it was like
drinking a brownie who doesn't want to
drink a brownie especially for breakfast
and especially when you know that
there's less than 0.5 grams of sugar in
it
i don't feel bad at all the cool thing
about heel is that you can use it as a
part of a balanced diet
you can have it in the morning as a
midday snack or even right before bed
because there's barely any sugar in it
look this is the first time you're
seeing me so i don't expect you to take
my word for it
but if you click the link in the
description below and you can get
started with fuel's complete protein
package today
and leave a comment below so you can let
me know which flavor you chose
i'm gonna go finish my push-ups enjoy
the rest of this react episode
i would love some suggestions for
animations to react to the animations
i'm looking for
are american western cartoons from like
the 90s that have crazy animation that
blows your minds
also animation from adult swim weird
surrealistic
sometimes low effort animation for 2am
are they even gonna read the comments of
course we read the comments where do you
think we get all the suggestions from
the show from
eric you bring so much knowledge here in
fact
one thing that i've tried to that i've
been inspired to do from you coming on
the show is you are
always particular with naming people who
are involved in the work that you're
talking about and i'm striving to try to
do more of that to learn the names
and say them out loud yeah we can be a
lot better about that we tend to just
like
oh someone did that so thank you for not
only sharing a bunch of your knowledge
with us
but also thank you for inspiring me to
be a better react host
thank you thank you both i i love this
uh channel i love you guys
thank you so much you know as much as we
geek out about this stuff
it's our job and we get to do this for a
living so
i just can't thank you enough for
getting to come here and talk about it
you bet man it's it's an honor and it's
a privilege
we're all very fortunate and i love i
love how many people
are clearly passionate about these
movies and shows that we are all working
on together in this industry
it's great to have someone come and be
like dude i love this scene this scene
blew my mind when i was a kid and it's
like yes we all have that kid inside of
us that that loved the stuff growing up
absolutely thanks for watching and we'll
see you next week